but first the original plan was for us
to be joined this morning by
sajid javid but after the health
secretary tested positive
a last-minute substitution was made and
his colleague robert generic
the local government secretary has come
off the bench he joins us
from birmingham thank you for joining us
in place of your colleague this morning
mr generic um who despite being
tested positive for covid is
is now self isolating let me just
ask you this we just got the statement
uh a few minutes ago
uh about the prime minister's situation
he says it says that
the prime minister and chancellor will
be participating in the daily contact
testing pilot
to allow them to continue work from
downing street
now um when the prime minister talked
about
freedom day did he just mean freedom for
him and the chancellor
and other cabinet colleagues and not for
the
millions who are supposed to go to work
but won't be
having access to that pilot
well good morning trevor and thanks for
having me on the program again
you're right to say that the prime
minister and the chancellor
were contacted by nhs track and trace
overnight which shows that the system is
working they're going to take part
in a daily testing pilot which is
available to a range of organizations
not just to
politicians it's being used by border
force
and by the transport for london that
runs the tube in london
for example and that means that they can
conduct
important government business but they
won't be able to go out socializing or
or meet other friends and family so
they'll have to limit
their their contact with other people as
much as they possibly can
but to your broader point we do believe
that we're able to move forward
tomorrow with stage four of the road map
that's really for two principal reasons
the prime minister set
two ambitious targets earlier in the
year
firstly that we wanted to ensure that
two-thirds of the adult population of
the country
had been double vaccinated by this point
and secondly and just as importantly
that every adult in the whole of the
united kingdom
had been offered at least one
vaccination and both of those tests
have been met so that does mean that
we're able to move forward but we'll be
doing so very cautiously
trevor because as you note cases are
rising
hospitalizations are rising and so we're
all going to have to exercise
personal responsibility and informed
good judgment
in the days ahead can i just bring you
back
mr generic to the question i asked you
which is
uh about this pilot which uh
the chancellor and the prime minister
are part of and as i understand it
uh mr gove when he had a pro
similar problem a little while ago
suddenly he also found himself part of a
pilot now these pilots are supposed to
be
random um is there a cabinet minister
who
won't have the luck to be
a subject in this pilot if he or she
suffers is pinged
well this is a pilot as i said that's
being uh
piloted by around 20 organizations
within the public sector
including border force including
transport for london
it's correct that the cabinet office and
downing street are part of the pilot
i'm not aware that other government
departments are
it means that you can be tested every
day
in specialist asymptomatic testing
centers such as the one
that's been set up in downing street it
means that the prime minister and the
chancellor will be able to conduct
the most essential government meetings
but the rest of their time
will be have to be spent isolating and
not as i say meeting up with
family or friends or socializing in any
other way so it's relatively
restricted thank you for the i entirely
appreciate your point trevor
that this isn't available yet to wider
members of the public and
i appreciate the frustration that they
might feel listening to this
they like me or other members of the
public who are pinged
will have to self-isolate in the usual
way and that's a really
important part of our plan to keep
covert under
control okay to be i i get i i get that
and
i appreciate you just said that if you
were pinged you'd have to self-isolate
but there's no evidence that that's what
happens you can see what it looks like
it looks like one rule for them and one
rule for the rest of us
well as i say this is this is a pilot
that's actually being used by
around 20 organizations so hundreds if
not thousands of
public sector staff who work in those
organizations will be able to use this
pilot we'll be learning from it and of
course if it's possible to roll it out
more broadly because it's proven to be
safe and successful
then we will do but for the rest of us
who are not yet part of that pilot
the crucial advice is if you are
contacted by nhs tester trace to take
that very seriously and
to self-isolate because although it can
be frustrating
that has helped us to prevent thousands
of cases
a study from the end of last year showed
that test and trace
had prevented six hundred thousand cases
and eight thousand unnecessary deaths in
just a three month period
leading up to the end of last year so it
is an important tool
in our armory to tackle the virus right
now
one last point on this if i may um do
you happen to know who decided
that downing street would be on that
list
no i don't know trevor but as i said it
is just one of several
large organizations uh some much larger
like border force and tfl that employs
many thousands of public sector
employees if the pilot is proven to be
safe and successful then i'm sure it
will inform
steps that will be available to the
wider public and remember of course
the within six weeks we do anticipate
self-isolation changing so in mid-august
the plan at the moment is that those
people who are double vaccinated and by
then it will be the overwhelming
majority of the population
won't need to self-isolate in the same
way that they do today
and from tomorrow the school bubble
system
will be retired and so that will also
make it easier
for members of the public i appreciate
it's been very difficult very
challenging indeed
for many schools in recent weeks
particularly the last fortnight where
the number of young people
uh having to self-isolate as a result of
bubbles and nhs testing trace has been
considerable
that will improve from next week will
then go into the school holidays
and for mid-august we anticipate we'll
be able to move forward
for the double vaccinated to a different
system
i want to come to vaccination of
children in a moment
but let's um follow what you've just
said last week half a million
people were pinged estimates
out this morning suggest that up to 10
million people
might be pinged in the coming weeks is
what you've just told me
that the government is clearly heading
towards a situation
in which fewer people are likely to be
pinged
or that we might uh lift self-isolation
the self-isolation regime for example as
the former prime minister tony blair
suggests this morning
that people who are double-jabbed would
not have to self-isolate is that what's
in prospect in next month
yes it is we've already said that we
want to get to a point by
the middle of august whereby those
people who've been double vaccinated
wouldn't have to self-isolate in the
same way they would take tests and have
to follow
all of the testing requirements but they
wouldn't need to self-isolate in the
same way
and that will be a significant step
forward the reason that we've chosen to
wait until
mid-august is to ensure that we get even
more people
double vaccinated because we know with
the delta variant
that one vaccine is good protection
but two vaccines is very significantly
better
in preventing both transmission and
serious illness and death and so by
waiting that extra six weeks
we should get to the point where a very
significant number of additional people
particularly the younger people in their
uh
late teens and twenties who have been
later to the vaccine program
have been double vaccinated myself for
example i've got my appointment uh next
week
to be getting my second vaccine and so
by waiting a bit longer we get
much more of the population into that
category that is the decision that we've
chosen to make obviously we'll keep that
under
review but we expect by the middle of
the month to be moving to a somewhat
different system which will be
less restrictive and easier for people
to manage but i do appreciate
that this is proving to be very
challenging obviously for schools
although they are about to go into the
school holidays
but particularly for businesses and
public services across the country
everybody understands that the
government is trying to make a judgment
between the progress of vaccination
and the speed of and variation in the
virus and it's a hard judgment to make
but let's test this out a little bit
let's start with
the issue of people who have been double
jabs like the health secretary
who have now uh contracted
covid what percentage of people
currently in hospital with covid
uh have been double jabs do you know
i don't have those figures trevor but
what what the health sector's case does
highlight is the fact that although the
current set of approved vaccines
are very good at helping people to avoid
serious illness
and there's no full safe vaccine that
can provide you with 100
protection what the current vaccines do
is ensure
between 80 and 90 percent improvement
in the likelihood of getting serious
illness
and even greater improvement in the
likelihood of death so
they take what is a otherwise a very
nasty
disease which can lead to serious
illness and death
and turn it into something that the
overwhelming majority of us
should be able to withstand but they
don't provide 100
protection and that's why i say again
despite the fact we're moving into the
next phase of the virus and it's right
to do so
we will need to do so with great caution
and each of us particularly the most
vulnerable continue
to show personal responsibility and
judgment in protecting ourselves
our loved ones and the wider public i
get that but let's just
get clear on what basis you're making
these judgments
not very long ago on this program the
former health secretary
matthew hancock told us that the
majority or the vast
majority i think overwhelming i think is
word he used majority of people
who are hospitalized were not double jab
what he suggested
to me was that actually being fully
vaccinated
provided pretty much complete protection
against the virus recurring
or being passed on is that still the
case
it is still the case the being
vaccinated with our current set of
vaccines
provides you as i said earlier but with
between 80 and 90 percent
protection still the case why not let
people who are double jabbed
uh be exempted from self-isolation
i'm sorry i didn't hear that that
question trevor there's quite a lot of
background noise if
if it is still if what mr hancock said
is still the case
why are you not exempting people
who are double jabbed from
self-isolation
given the economic and uh problems
and the chaos frankly that the amount of
pinging that's going to take place
will cause this country
well we've chosen to wait a short period
six weeks
on medical advice which is to ensure
that even more of the population
get double vaccinated that that has two
effects of course there's a question of
fairness
because that ensures that younger people
can be double vaccinated before
something is opened up to those who are
more fortunate and have been able to be
vaccinated sooner because they were
older or more vulnerable it also means
that by having more people
double vaccinated transmission will be
reduced within wider society because of
course a vaccine doesn't just protect
yourself
it helps to a lesser extent but
nonetheless an important extent
to protect other people by reducing the
risk of transmission
so it was a precautionary step i
appreciate that
but one that we took on the basis of the
medical and scientific advice that by
the middle of
august we'd be in the position where a
much
larger number of individuals
particularly amongst those in their 20s
who statistically
are more likely to be out socializing
meeting other people
more regularly more of those individuals
will be double vaccinated i think that's
the right thing to do
but i do appreciate that it will produce
some further
uh disruption and frustration in the
coming weeks but i would
again urge people to ensure that they do
have the nhs
the app on their phones that it's fully
switched on
we're seeing actually more people
downloading the app than ever before so
the evidence is positive but then if you
do get contacted by track and trace of
course
to follow all the steps that are
required because it is a really
important
part of our our tool kit for tackling
the virus at this
critical stage as cases are still rising
hospitalizations are increasing and we
won't really expect this
uh wave of the virus to peak until
late august maybe even early september
so there are going to be some quite
challenging weeks ahead
mr generic um two points first of all
you've been clear that actually there's
a lot of stuff we don't there a lot of
things we don't know
we can't be certain about and everybody
knows that secondly
you've used the word caution or
precautionary i think now half a dozen
times i'll be noting it
during this interview why are we still
going ahead
with freedom day tomorrow
well as the prime minister said earlier
in the week there's no easy
or straightforward answer to the
question of
when we should move forwards and move
from a system of legal requirements to
one of personal
responsibility but now does seem like
the logical time
we're moving into the summer holidays
for school
which will mean there'll be less
transmission amongst young people and
families
the weather is good and so that is the
most benign climate
for tackling the virus and we modeled
what might happen if we were to delay
for another short period
for example till september and there
wasn't a compelling case
to do so so now does seem like the right
time to move forwards
but we have to be honest with the public
that
cases are rising as i say we haven't yet
reached the peak
of this wave of infection and so we all
do need
to approach this carefully and
cautiously and in a gradual
way and we will all need to exercise
good judgment
we are moving from that time where the
state told you what to do
things were mandated as a matter of law
to one which had to come
at some point where we trusted people we
trusted businesses
and organizations and gave them the
information they needed
to make good judgments all right um
can i just say can i just be frank and
say i
understand all of that but i think that
some people
will feel that what you're really saying
is that the government is essentially
being
blown by the course of events rather
than having a plan
now there could be some very specific
things that you could say
we're definitely going to do for example
you could decide as have several other
countries united states and israel
to vaccinate children and that would
make sure
that we reduce the circulation of the
virus
and the possibility of more variant why
not well firstly trevor we do have a
plan and that plan
fortunately is working we set out that
we would vaccinate
by this point in fact we've done it
earlier than we said we would do
two-thirds of the adult population with
two jabs
we said that we would ensure every adult
in the whole united kingdom
is offered about children we've managed
to achieve both of those two things
i've just asked you about children
rather than adults i wonder if we could
deal with that
understood now that we have offered the
jab to all adults and of course there
are still some that need to come forward
i'd strongly urge them to do so
we will be taking advice in the coming
days from the jcvi we haven't yet
received their final advice
on whether to extend the vaccine rollout
to children
that seems like a sensible thing to do
and so
we will be looking carefully at their
advice when we receive it we expect it
very soon
on whether or not we should open up the
vaccine program
in the first instance to those children
who are just
short of their 18th birthday to those
children who have particular
vulnerabilities and those children who
are in households
where there are people who are
particularly vulnerable that seems like
a sensible way for us to proceed
but ministers will need to make that
decision when they're armed with the
final advice from the jcvr
jcvi our expert advisors and as i said i
expect that we will be receiving that by
that advice
very soon okay uh mr before we finish
can i um
ask you to to return to your normal
position
uh on the pitch in the team and that is
as uh
local government minister uh you are one
of the two secretaries of state
responsible for social care the prime
minister said
on the steps of downing street on the
moment he became prime minister
that the government had a plan
prepared which it would reveal
for social care he will become
uh he will have hit two years as prime
minister
in the next few weeks when are we going
to see that plan
that was prepared two years ago
well the prime minister intends to
honour that commitment we've said that
we're going to bring forward a plan
before the end of the year and i expect
it will be published much sooner than
that
we're working intensively on it as local
government secretary of course i
play a role in that also the health
secretary and the chancellor so you
won't have to wait
very much longer as local government
secretary i know how incredibly
important it is that we put the
financing
of social care on a sustainable footing
it's been tested
very severely over the course of the
last 15 months people who
work in the sector have done an
absolutely magnificent
job as have local councils in keeping it
going
but now is the moment where we need to
map out how we have a long-term
sustainable future for social care that
protects the elderly and the most
vulnerable in society
and ensures that people do not have to
lose their homes and that the people who
work in the sector
get looked after as well so we say
what for the prime minister to set out
his proposals when you say
when you say before the end of the year
did you mean the end of the calendar
year which would be two and a half years
since the prime minister made his pledge
or before the end of the this
parliamentary the end the parliamentary
set recess which at least would just be
two years
[Applause]
well parliament goes into recess in a
couple of days time uh
we've said in the past that we would be
bringing forward the proposals before
the end of this calendar year
but i believe we will be in a position
to set out proposals much sooner than
that
but if i'm afraid you just have to wait
a little bit longer all i can say to you
is that all of us who are involved in
this care very much about it
i think it's one of the most important
generational issues that we have to
tackle as a country
and we'll be publishing proposals soon
mr generic thank you you know what a
patient
person i am obviously not everybody is
as patient as me we'll see when that
uh plan arrives thank you very much for
your time
thank you